okay we're talking of change actually
petrol prices have hit a record high up
28 pence a liter in the last year now
that i mean guys i mean that sounds
pretty bad for the motorist and we all
need to get about but is there a
positive in all of this is this going to
push people away from from fossil fuels
and onto electric vehicles perhaps more
quickly sepi what do you think
the first thing i'd say on this is that
it's yet another blow in the rising cost
of living being experienced by the uk
public and it comes really quickly off
the back of this year's gas price hike
seeing wholesale gas prices at record
highs and you know we have to look at
what you know these things have in
common and again it's highlighting the
fact that british public and industries
are vulnerable to these volatile and
increasingly expensive fossil fuels so
it does highlight the urgency to help
the public transition away from fossil
fuels and one positive
announcement in that regard was actually
last week's net zero strategy where the
government announced a zero emissions
vehicle mandate uh which is requiring
manufacturers to sell an increasing
percentage of zero emissions vehicles
each year possibly from 2024 and that
will help actually drive down the cost
of reduction sooner
so that
ordinary households can afford them just
a quick point on that is actually we're
looking at evs being cheaper to buy than
petrol and diesel in about five years
time and that's purely through
plummeting tech and manufacturing costs
yeah and that is going to be important
because there's a big price gap at the
moment is isn't that chilly but this
this new survey says 24 of people buying
a new car in the next year so they
intend to buy electric or hybrid perhaps
you could say it's not enough but it i
mean it's a big chunk of people
it is and the policy that stops new
diesel cars being sold in 2030 is is is
a really important policy what we
realize from sort of the academic
studies is that the price elasticity of
petrol uh isn't that high in the short
term so when the price of petrol goes up
people can't quickly and immediately
switch they need more important
structural things like encouragement of
the government to fund a good car
scrappage scheme and to enable electric
and hybrid vehicles to become dominant
small streets so of course today in
london is the launch of the ulis scheme
which uh mayor khan has has as a
sudhikan has has lauded as a good way of
getting a lot of diesel and petrol cars
off the road and we we very firmly
support that the one thing i would add
is that when you look at the the
marketplace as it exists now
we're looking at the way that all fossil
fuels across the energy value chain
impact everyone it isn't just motorists
it's also utility companies that are
suffering terrible damage from incredi
increasingly volatile oil and gas
markets so transition for the public is
not just about transport it's about
energy as a whole it's about our
utilities it's about transport it's
about our manufacturing it's about
reorganizing society in a way that makes
things better for everyone
you